[AUDIO LOGO]
Happy Thursday, everybody.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
I hope everyone's
having a great week.
So the Data Science
Hangout is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to hear about what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
So it happens every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you're ever
watching these on YouTube,
you can always
add the calendar--
there's a calendar link in the
details below because we'd love
to have you join us live too.
But together, we're
all dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everyone.
We love hearing from
everybody no matter your level
of experience or area of work.
It is totally OK to just
listen in if you want,
but there's also
three ways you can
jump in and ask questions or
provide your own perspective
on certain topics.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom,
you can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you want me to
read it out as well.
And then we also
have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And I'm sure Hannah will
share that in the chat
here in just a second.
So Eric said this would be
a fun off the cuff session.
We're doing things a
little bit different today.
So our featured leader for
today was unfortunately sick.
So we'll be rescheduling
his session to the 18th.
So for today, we are all
the featured leaders.
So we can all ask each other
questions to the audience.
So still ask questions
the same way.
But I was talking with a few
of you an hour ago on LinkedIn,
and both Libby and Mike
said I should put myself
in the hot seat here first.
So I am happy to
get started here.
But I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I lead our pro
community at Posit
where I'm always
looking for new ways
to bring customers together
and our community together
to be able to listen to feedback
and learn from each other.
To give you a little bit
about my background here.
So I've been at
Posit for 5 and 1/2
years, which I can't believe
how fast that time has gone by.
Of course, when I
joined, it was RStudio.
But I actually
started off in sales.
So I was working with our
new professional customers.
And in those conversations
with customers,
people were always
asking me, what
are other people
doing with your tools
or what are people
doing in my industry?
And we had some stories and
customer stories on the site,
but I didn't really have a
great way to connect people.
And I was just thinking
about all these amazing use
cases and stories I was hearing
from other customer calls,
but I couldn't say like,
hey, I just got off
a call with so-and-so.
This is what they're doing.
So I started planning these
enterprise community meetups
a few years ago because I was
also running a Boston user
group.
And that actually helped
me transition into the role
that I'm in now, so leading
our professional community.
And so that's just a little
bit of background on my role.
But outside of work, a few
things that I like to do--
so I like to play guitar.
Not professional or
anything, but it's
nice to be able to get my mind
off of work or outside away
from a screen.
I like to run, snowboard, be
active, do things outside.
And it's been really fun
getting to learn from you all,
the things that you do outside
of your data world too.
But yeah, that's me.
I'll kick things off here
as our featured leader.
But as I said, we're all
the featured leaders today.
So any questions that you
have, go put them in the chat
or on Slido.
I can absolutely kick
things off with starting
talking about community.
I love talking about community.
So any questions you
all have about that,
happy to answer too.
OK.
Libby, I'm going to have you
ask this question here live.
I'm curious.
I'm always curious about
what people thought
they would be doing when they
were in high school versus what
they're doing right now because
mine is so wildly different.
Because I feel like nobody
in high school is like,
I want to be an analyst or I
want to be a data scientist.
And community leader inside
of a software open source
and software company is
something you probably
couldn't have imagined.
Right.
Absolutely.
I actually just--
I'm very indecisive.
I never knew exactly
what I wanted to do.
I wasn't one of those
people who are like,
yes, I want to be a doctor
and I 100% know that.
But it's funny, I was thinking
about this the other day
because I went to Bentley
University and Business School
and my major was
information design
and corporate communication.
I was thinking like,
that's actually
what I'm doing right
now, which at the time,
I didn't even know
what those roles would
be when that was my major.
I was thinking it was more
like public relations.
But something that I had shared
at the RStudio conference
last year is that I
feel like a lot of--
oh, Bill just put
that in the chat.
But a lot of what I know
about community building
has nothing to do
with school or work.
I shared in my conference
talk that a lot of it
actually came from
watching my mom who's
run a bar for 38 years.
Her and her friend owned a
bar in Groton, Connecticut.
And so watching the way that my
mom interacted with customers--
new and regular customers.
And I should always like
walk up to every table
and check on people
and introduce yourself.
Little things like that
always stuck in my mind,
and I felt like
they always came--
it just felt like
common sense or things
that came natural to me.
And then I realized in preparing
for that conference talk
like that really applies
to community building.
I can share the blog too if
anybody's ever curious or wants
to check it out too.
Ahnas, I see you have
your hand raised.
Yes.
So first of all, Rachel,
thank you for sharing that.
And I really think that
some of those fields that
relate to customer service,
the skills are so transferable,
and you're applying it
in different ways see.
You it at restaurants,
but you can apply it
in everyday business
settings, and I
think that's very powerful.
Myself personally, I've
had roles in food service
and I feel like I carry
that wherever I go.
But a question or a topic I
want to open to the community
if possible.
So I'm not sure
here on this call
if anyone has, within
a large enterprise,
been part of the initiation
of using our solutions
or our tools essentially
that I find myself
in my current role--
in big organizations,
it's a little bit harder
to get that traction or get
that momentum or get that trust.
And I'm curious if
anyone on the call
has thoughts or ideas to
share about that topic
or what have they done or
how have they implemented
using our more openly
or more commonly
in these large organizations.
Absolutely.
I see Eric has some
thoughts on this issue.
If you want to start.
And anybody else
who has thoughts,
feel free to just raise
your hand here too.
Yeah.
I mean, it's a very
important issue
and something I wrestled
with in my early career.
I touched a little bit on
this, I think, in the Hangout
from last year.
But I think for me what
drove it to leadership
the value of what open
source could bring is--
I hate to say, I took matters
in my own hands in one way
by spinning up
the infrastructure
myself with a little help from
IT to get the RStudio Server
and Shiny Server spun up.
And I just show them a couple
simple prototypes, nothing
that fancy by today's standards,
but then it just organically
grew.
So I was like in sports--
some of my favorite people I
follow in the sports world,
they all lead by example.
They're not going to shout
at the teammates about,
oh, you did bad or this
is what we need to do.
They just go and do
it, and then they
bring people along the way.
So I took a calculated risk.
At the time I was
sewing on, I didn't
realize how risky it was
until after the fact,
but it ended up working.
So I think leading
by example and trying
to get some examples
to leadership of like,
this is what is possible.
But in order to
make this happen,
you need some support
to push it further.
But just getting those
examples in the right
eyes people that are ready to
embrace doing something new,
not always following on the
status quo way of doing things.
I think that's my
general advice.
Thanks, Eric.
I see, Zac, you have
your hand raised too
if you want to jump in here.
Yeah.
So I'm going to match Eric.
I was the IT guy that would
help somebody like Eric stand up
the infrastructure and present
the need to the leadership
team.
And I handled a big project
for a very small life science
organization many
years ago where
it was a computational chemist.
I was like, hey, here's
the tools we need.
Here's the space we need to
pitch to the organization.
And present day, they've got a
data center and multiple Nova
sacks, and many different data
analysts running their pipeline
that they built on R. And
so I think it absolutely
takes a tribe.
Thank you both.
Sorry.
I see Marlene has a
great question in the chat
and a thread everybody's
citing about what profession
you envisioned yourself
in in high school?
I see Yu, you had asked a
question to the audience here.
Do you want to jump
in and ask that?
Sure.
So hi everyone.
I'm just wondering
how is the R--
so far how, is the R company's--
what is the company's response
to ChatGPT?
Every company has
a concrete plan
to use it to create
value for the business.
Right now, we are having some
weekly meetings on ChatGPT
to discuss how to use
it for our business.
We are a financial
service company.
So for us, transparency
is very important.
The model need to be
interpretable and expalinable.
So we cannot use it
directly, obviously.
And we can not give any
of our customer data
to the server of Open
AI ChatGPT to write
it and that kind of response.
So we are planning to
build our in-house--
a similar in-house model.
Here, I'm just
wondering, any company
here have any concrete
plan on ChatGPT,
how to use it for the business?
You had to throw a
hard one in there, Yu.
Anybody have thoughts on that?
I don't have a
great answer yet.
I mean, we're all trying to
figure it out, so to speak.
But I can share that in
our internal company,
we are first--
our [INAUDIBLE] of
the year was one
of my colleagues showing
how they were using ChatGPT
as their virtual code assistant
to build a Shiny app quite
quickly.
Yeah.
And everybody, was blown away,
and it actually wasn't too bad.
Much better than the last
time I tried something
like this, a copilot, about
a year and a half ago.
So we're seeing potential
is like that virtual pair
of programmer that you could
bounce ideas off of maybe
for a language you're
not as familiar with.
Like for me, I'm still on this
JavaScript learning journey
even though I've been using
Shiny since the very beginning.
I've been able to be
a consumer of Shiny
without having to know
too much about the nuts
and bolts behind
it, but now I've
taken that extra transition to
having to extend it a bit more.
So that's how we're
starting with it.
But in my industry of life
sciences, we have to be--
I hate to say it, pretty
cautious about how
we're using this, but we
are very much intrigued
by what it can do from an
efficiency standpoint for sure.
Yeah.
You see a lot of thoughts
here in the chat about it too.
I think Marlene, you
weighed in first about this.
You want to jump in?
[LAUGHS] So everybody asked
me because I'm the one data
scientist in our family of
companies, what's the deal,
yow, with ChatGPT?
And overall, I try
to say, it's a tool.
With a pencil, you can
draw, you can write prose,
you could stab somebody.
So I keep telling them, it's
just like any other tool,
depends on how it's wielded.
But so far, the biggest
nonsupporters of it
has been the
communications department.
Anybody in journalism is
very threatened by it,
but I keep trying to tell them,
it's great for brainstorming.
Don't think of it as
like polished copy right.
So it's funny.
I think you're going
to end up being--
each one of you,
you're going to end up
having a lot of
people come to you
and trying to be
seen as an expert--
a domain expert in it.
My advice to you
especially, try
to be objective
even though you have
your own opinions about it.
It's important for us to be
good stewards of knowledge.
So I do my best to tell
people, envision a lot,
be cautious, but also
feel free to dream
because it's not going away.
So that's been my
message to anybody
who's asking my
company, which has
been a lot in the
last couple of weeks.
That's for sure.
So that's my $0.02.
My message is
always talk to legal.
[LAUGHTER]
I know there are a lot
of concerns about--
not only, obviously, sending
your data to their servers,
but even if you have a local
instance of a model running.
There's always concern
about bias in the model
and there's always concern about
some of the copyright stuff.
So if you're producing
code and then using it,
where did that code come from?
That's all obfuscated
behind the model.
So definitely, I'm so
excited about the tech.
I know people in my
company are, but gosh,
everyone has to be so careful.
This was a problem before.
Right.
Learn from Samsung
who's shared a bunch
of sensitive
information with a model
and now it's all out
in the public domain.
So be careful.
Yeah.
I see Andy, you put
a thought about how
you might be using ChatGPT.
Do you want to jump in there?
Yeah, sure.
So I work for Teach for
America as a data scientist.
So we have 10,000 applications
coming every year,
and we do a first pass
with our NLP models.
But we've had this
huge challenge
now because we are the target
audience for the early adopters
of GPT, which is
college aged students
who are writing essays.
And because we basically have
trained college age students
to write the exact same essay
that GPT wants to write,
we're now dealing with this
huge repercussion of all
of our historical
training data sets
for NLP passing are
trained prior to GPT,
and now we have
this huge influx.
So it's really become
a challenge not on--
we also use GPT
internally, but it's
more on the receiving end of
seeing the products of GPT
has been a huge challenge.
Thank you.
I see Mike, you had
a question earlier.
It's funny to be
like, hey, Mike.
You had a question for
me, can you ask it?
Hey, Rachel?
How would you like to be
[INAUDIBLE] that I asked you
in the chat.
It was basically--
I know that you have come
from a marketing background.
And so oftentimes, I've said
that data scientists are geeks.
And so if we're
selling to people,
we're selling to other geeks.
And we're trying to hook them in
with how clever the solution is
or how it's going to help
us do geeky stuff better.
Knowing about
marketing, what skills
would you recommend
data scientists
to look into for selling
upwards to managers and people
who aren't the geeks?
Yeah.
So something I think
that is really important
is actually taking the time
to make something look pretty,
and there's a lot
of tools out there
that you can use to do that.
One that I always use
for like groups as Canva
because there's a bunch of
different design templates.
But I always find if you
put a little bit of effort
into what something looks like,
people take it more seriously.
And so I was thinking about that
with showing an idea for an app
to your leadership team trying
to actually use the colors that
match your brand or
putting your logo in it
so that people immediately see
it as something like oh, this
is how we would use
this at our company.
Even if it's completely
made up data,
I think having the
brand guidelines there,
it just changes the
way people view it.
That's one thing I've
been thinking about.
But I mean, I still
struggle with this too,
pushing ideas forward.
I literally just got off a call
about something a little bit--
probably an hour ago.
And one mistake I made was not
thinking of the sales process
with my own idea.
If I get really excited
about something,
I want to go make it
happen immediately.
And sometimes that's
good, but sometimes you
need to make sure that you are
actually bringing everybody
on board to see your vision
and your goal for the project,
especially in
leadership, so that they
can help push it forward.
Because I've learned, you're not
always going to be in the room
when somebody is
discussing your ideas.
So it's important that
they understand it too.
Thanks.
Does that help?
[LAUGHS] I was looking for
a different direction there.
Well, it's--
I guess there's several
directions I was thinking.
One is we have a good
solution or we've
got a good idea that we want
to get management buy in from,
which is a tricky process.
And you get a limited
amount of their time.
So how do you ensure that all
the things they want to know
are ticked?
Yeah.
There's another
question, which is possibly
for a different
day, but it's more
you're trying to sell
to your peers, so
to other data scientists.
Hey, we've got a process
well defined here.
How many times do--
and in how many ways
do you keep telling
them that same thing
so that the thing drops?
Yeah.
I mean, a piece of advice
I can share here just
from community building and
also getting our team on board
to come to events
as well is just
having one on one conversations
with people to learn about some
of the problems that they're
facing every day in their work,
and then trying to incorporate
that into whatever you
are proposing.
So that you can build them
up as your own champions
to help you pushing
this forward.
That's been really
helpful for me.
I know that it's
trying to compare
like two different things
here because I'm not
a data scientist
pushing this forward,
but maybe even just thinking
about pushing the Data Science
Hangout forward and
making sure that people
see the value in that too.
Anybody else have
thoughts on this
and selling to the leadership
and sharing your ideas?
I will say that
getting to know people
on a more personal
level is really helpful.
If you can have
conversations with leadership
that are not about work
and get to know them
and what matters to
them generally in life,
and even what matters to
them in a business sense.
Everybody has a different
thing that they're championing
and that they're really
interested in moving forward.
And so finding out
what is individually
motivating to these people
that you're trying to talk to
can be really helpful because
then you can speak to that
and you're not just blowing
your own horn a bunch.
You can blow their horn.
I think that that's really
helpful and important.
Absolutely.
And I've been trying to
take some of the advice
that you all share
here too and all
the different future leaders.
And I remember, I
think Emmy [INAUDIBLE]
was sharing about repeating
the things that you really
care about.
And not just
thinking because you
said something or proposed
something as an idea one
time that it's going
to be accepted.
You have to keep
talking about it.
And then I've also been
trying to put my ideas
in the lens of our company OKRs
or objectives and key results
so that when they're talking
about those at a leadership
level, they think
about my project
because it was put into those
exact words or those terms.
Ahnas, I see you have
your hand raised.
Yeah.
Just a little--
I guess in addition to
that piece of advice,
I would say that when
speaking with leaders,
sometimes saying less is more.
We tend to overshare the
technical aspects and we're
very--
and sometimes, we feel the
need to talk into those details
to make our point.
But they're not as interested
in the technical pieces.
Just speak to them at
a normal human level,
and they trust you as an expert.
There is that aspect.
You just have to come from
their angle as much as possible.
But I feel like that's something
I've learned more recently when
I'm explaining a model or
I'm explaining a solution.
I feel like I want to go into
some of the technical details
where it's like that's not--
they're not too worried
about that piece.
They're just worried about the--
how does this impact
them or how is this
going to impact organization?
Definitely.
Kaitlin, I see you just put
an example into the chat.
If you want to weigh in here.
Yeah, sure.
So I was just saying,
at my old company,
I did end up pitching data for
a good center of excellence,
and it took a few
pitch decks that I
made on campus, by the way.
But now I think the
biggest feedback
I got from that is just
echoing what Ahna said here,
don't try and be technical
with non-technical people.
That's truly not
what they care about.
And I think putting yourself
in the shoes of whoever you're
pitching to is so important.
And focusing not on the
outcomes for yourself
or I want to do this
idea because xyz
is my passion, da, da, da.
They don't really care that
that's your passion so much,
but they want to know how it's
going to help them actually
not how it's going to help you
in your career and your future.
But so yeah, I ended up
doing a couple of pitch decks
definitely, a lot of meetings.
And then I think
something that's
really helpful for
higher UPS to see
is almost a 30, 60, 90 day
plan on what the outcomes may
be of your idea.
That's really helpful.
Thanks, Caitlin.
Yeah.
I see there was a
question in the chat
if there's a Slack or Discord
or some group for everybody
to connect after the
fact with the Hangouts
or where to find the
Hangout recordings?
I see Libby mentioned
the YouTube.
If anybody wants to share
the YouTube playlist where
all the recordings are,
that would be super helpful.
But right now, we don't
have a great solution
for the ongoing conversations.
I would love to have
that in the future.
Right now, we just
have a LinkedIn group,
which I'll share here.
I know that's not the best
format for having conversation
sometimes, but it's
what we have right now.
But we can definitely explore
other options there too.
A Slido question
that was asked is--
for the whole audience, do you
have any favorite data science
podcasts or YouTube channels?
I see a lot being shared.
Data humans.
Libby's podcast.
Absolutely
Also, me, myself, and AI too
have been pretty interesting.
They just recently
had a couple from--
one was an airline.
I think it was--
I want to say it
was Delta, and then
another from the LEGO group.
So as a LEGO nerd,
that was also really
cool to see data science and AI
and LEGO and things like that.
That's cool.
Thank you all for sharing
them in the chat too.
We'll have to go
collect all these.
Mike, I see you have
your hand raised?
Yeah.
I mean, we can't talk about data
humans with Libby on this call
without Libby giving us
the elevator pitch of--
Yes, absolutely.
Yes.
I would be happy to, yeah.
did humans doesn't
have a ton of episodes.
It's something I'm
doing on the side.
It's like every
month or six weeks
whenever I can get it
in and convince somebody
to come on the podcast.
But I started it
because I realized
that there was a lack of
vulnerability and realness
when a lot of people,
especially people on LinkedIn,
are talking about this science.
It's like all wins.
Oh, I'm doing this big
huge modeling thing.
And when you meet them,
sometimes you realize,
they aren't actually
doing that for work.
They're doing that
on the side for fun.
Not everybody is a full
time R package developer.
It has the potential
to make us all
feel like, everybody else
is doing something so much
cooler than we are.
They must be.
Like, they must
be doing something
so much cooler than what I'm
doing because what I'm doing
is a bunch of Excel still
and my company doesn't
want to have a code tidyverse
approach to analytics and all
this stuff.
And really, we're all pretty
similar on the whole--
there's still a ton of data
people using Excel and using
SaaS and using things
that are not crazy
huge machine learning models.
So I just wanted a place to talk
to everyday data people, not
CEOs.
Because there's
a ton of podcasts
that are CEOs or super senior
data scientists at Spotify
or whatever it is,
and that's fantastic.
Learning from those
people is great.
But what I'm interested in is
the everyday people like me
and people who are just
doing normal stuff what
are they doing.
We don't get a peek behind that
vulnerable curtain very often.
And then, of course, Eric
is also on this call.
Eric was the first podcast
I ever listened to.
When I first started learning
R, I felt really alone.
There's no way that
anybody else is
this excited about a
programming language as I am.
I'm like sitting there in my
first R programming class.
Everybody's really bored.
I'm super excited.
I have a copy of the
grammar of graphics.
I am absolutely just high
invested in this thing,
and I found Eric's podcast.
And I was like, there were
other people out there like me.
[LAUGHS]
Thank you, Libby.
And Eric, now we're going
to have to have you give--
Yes, please.
--a little overview too.
It's amazing.
That's why I started
the whole thing.
Is I wanted to
connect with people.
And I cannot think of a better
thing I could have done even
though I was really running with
no knowledge of how to do any
of this whatsoever.
But no.
Really, it's about
connecting with people,
but I'm really
passionate about sharing
what other people are doing that
I'm learning from every day.
And so that's why the R
Weekly Project, once I
got involved with that,
I realized, well, yeah,
we have the website.
Every week, we have a new issue.
But let's have another avenue to
deliver this great content out
there.
And that's why I just started
our weekly highlights,
and it's been a
joy to work with.
I cannot do it alone.
I say this every week.
So Mike Thomas, my
co-host here, is
one of the biggest
motivators for me
to keep going because it's
a weekly show with a day
job with kids.
It is a lot to fit
in, but R is my hobby.
I'm still-- open
source is my jam.
I love talking about it.
So I figured, just throw it
out there, see if it resonates.
And sure enough, it has.
But yeah, I love
hearing the stories
and being able to put
the spotlight on others
in the community.
They were doing awesome things.
So it's a true pleasure to do.
This feels like such
a heartwarming community
call right now.
And I just wanted to say--
take an opportunity
to say, thank you
to everybody here
who is also helped
make this space what it is.
And I absolutely love getting
to hang out with you all every
Thursday.
And if I think back to it--
I think we're going on about
two years in a month or so,
which is amazing.
But if I think back
to two years ago
and I thought we didn't
have a featured leader
and we were just going
to join in all chat,
I would be freaking out.
And I just love that
we're all able to have
this open conversation here.
So I just want to say thank
you to all of you here too.
Thank you, Rachel.
Everybody, round of
applause to Rachel.
[LAUGHS]
You're our fearless leader--
Thank you.
--whether you know it or not.
Rory, I see you had some
thoughts on something
we were talking about a little
bit earlier on the topic
of spreading ideas.
Do you want to jump in here?
Can you guys hear me?
I just hadn't had
audio or video one.
Yes, I can.
Yeah.
Just a little background.
So I work here as a
behavioral scientist,
and my big interest is in
organizational network analysis
and a lot of relationship
dynamic in organizations.
And I think one of the
things that doesn't often
get talked about is how the
relationships that you have
are really important with
influencing people and getting
buy in.
And one of my favorite
resources or people to follow
is this guy named Mike Arena
who used to be at a leading
their talent organization.
And he has recently done a
lot of research on remote work
on hybrid work on
relationships and innovation.
And he's generally found
for a lot of that research
that it's best to spend a lot
of time incubating your ideas.
If you come up with an idea,
you're passionate about it,
like were talking
about, Rachel, it's
great to socialize
that with a few people,
especially if they're
at your level.
And maybe they can help
you improve that idea.
And once you really
build that out, then it
becomes a good
opportunity to scale
and you have a network
of support around that
can help you build that up.
I've seen that play out a lot.
I don't know if anyone else
has had a similar experience
in their organization
where they felt
once they had a
good coalition, they
were able to get
somebody buy in.
But I feel like we don't always
talk about the relationships
we have either at work
or in our personal lives
and how much of
a difference that
makes in influencing people
to do one thing or another.
So I just want to
call that out in case
that was helpful to
people as they're
trying to pitch new ideas.
Absolutely.
Thank you, Rory.
Yeah, no problem.
Anybody else have ideas
on that topic to share too?
Yeah.
I'll just reinforce.
We did the same thing when
we started our internal user
group.
It was started as
just an R user group,
and it was basically
the same five of us
that were interested and just
presenting back and forth
to each other each
month with very little
variety in the presenters.
But eventually, we
started to expand it,
started to include
other source languages.
And now, we've literally
got hundreds of users
across of the company
pitching new ideas,
sharing things that they've
done, and just really cool
to have every stage too.
We've got folks
who are brand new
and have heard of R, Python,
or something and want to learn.
We've also got people who are
super advanced and teaching
very complex topics.
So that snowball effect
has worked really well.
That's awesome.
I see Abigail, you have started
a thread here in the chat
here too.
If you want to jump in and
share any perspective there.
And no worries.
I don't want to put
anybody on the spot here.
But yeah, any other
thoughts on this?
I see, Ken, you had a
question around storytelling.
Do you want to jump in
and ask that to everybody?
Sure.
Get myself on video here.
Yeah.
I think the
discussion going back,
I think Mr. Smith was the
one who kicked it off really
of how do you get decision
makers to buy into your ideas?
Some of the stuff I'm seeing--
I do analyst
relations for Posit.
So I'm talking with some of
the market research firms
like Gartner and Forrester.
There's a lot of there's
a lot of research there
that talks about the use of--
the correct use of the right
tool to get your point across.
And I wondered if any of you had
been taking data storytelling
courses at any point?
Some of you have replied
here to help you figure out
what's the right tool to get
across how do you present data
to be able to persuade people?
And then another
point that came up
I thought was also
interesting was
the idea of there's
proactive storytelling
versus using a self
service method of getting
your ideas out there.
So both of those
topics, I think, are--
I find very, very useful.
And I know that Rachel's found
some other customers that--
one customer talked about
using an interactive web
app versus sending out
a 200 page PDF report
and how that really
changed their interactions
with decision makers.
So it's curious to hear
more about other people's
experiences in that respect
I know.
There is a few people who had
thoughts on this in the chat.
And Jim, I see you
were first there
do you want to share
any perspective here?
Just really quickly.
I find that we end up going
down one of two paths often
depending on the client
and the environment
and the skill sets
of the people.
Sometimes it is in fact
a matter of storytelling
and getting it down into maybe
even a 5 minute set of slides.
But just as often,
the exercise is
a matter of empowering
other analysts
or other operational
people whose day
job is doing whatever, and we
want to make their life better.
And so we're
going to push data
through some kind of
a layer to an endpoint
so they can use it in the
system they're comfortable with.
And so it's more of a using
the endpoint that they're
comfortable with and
maybe less storytelling,
more developing empathy for the
person you're trying to help
do what they do better.
Thank you.
I see Marlene, you have
your hand raised too.
Want to jump in?
Yeah.
So I'm in a master's
program right now,
and I'm literally in the
middle of a class that's
focused completely around
communicating data, which
I found admirable.
They actually spend the time--
it's not even-- you're
not touching data
at all in this class.
They want you to make sure
that you identify your target
audience, that you use the right
tone and language, that you
make your point easy
to follow, things
like that we take for granted
and are super nuanced,
just like presentation giving.
They force you to really
reexamine your habits,
use concise language.
And so I think that goes in
line with what the comments made
about communicating data.
It's not just an
effective visualization
or an effective tool to
get the point across,
but really making sure your
words back up your point.
And then secondly, I went
to a water data conference
out here in Southern California.
I don't know if anybody
else on the call
was able to go to this.
It's called the California
Data Conference,
but it's all around water.
So it's a little misleading.
But there was an excellent
speaker, and her name
and eludes me right now.
But she gave me an
entire presentation
that was just gorgeous.
And it was about
highlighting signals so
that when you're talking
to somebody in management,
that you're not just giving
them a bunch of data fluff.
That you're really
getting their attention
to the part of the visual that
the outliers or the signal
and whatnot.
And she also referenced
a couple of books
that I thought were incredible.
One was-- sorry.
It's called Signal.
I believe it's out of
print now, but there
is a newer version of it.
So maybe you can hunt it down.
But yes, I think totally,
it's about saying it well,
saying it short and concise,
saying the language they
understand, and then giving
them the visual to back it
up totally.
Because usually if you
put it in their hands
and they get some real
visceral feel around what
the possibility is, it helps.
But half the time, you can't
get in the door with them,
and that's where probably the
other half of us who are still
in that frustrated
vicious cycle of not being
able to get management to help
really build infrastructure
or tools or teams to support
your work are falling into.
So--
It's interesting
when you said it's
hard to get in the door
with decision makers.
What makes it hard?
So some of it is time
because there are usually
1,000 other things on
their plate that will be--
take more precedent than we
need our infrastructure updated.
Unless you're
building is on fire,
they're never going to
see that as something that
really needs attention.
At least that's what my
organization has been like.
They're like, our
computers still run.
We're still crunching data.
Our analysts still
do these reports.
We're good.
We don't need a single
source of truth or anything
like that, which is crazy.
And then the other part is,
even if you get in the door,
it's, well, what
is the ROI on this?
And sometimes it's hard to do.
I don't have people's salaries.
I can go to HR or
to our accounting
and try to get some
of those projections,
but it also seems
off putting to them
that this analyst scientists
in the corner of the company
is asking for these things.
So it just-- it can
be tricky to try
to give the value add right
up front where they go,
aha, I get it.
Instead, you have to
say, something's broken
and I need to fix it.
And then you have to prove that
it's actually broken enough
that it needs fixing.
So I hope that makes sense, but
those are kind of the two cases
I've run into, both in
the same organization.
Thank you, Marlene.
That course sounds great too.
You're reminding me that I--
oh, wow, that link
is really long.
But you're reminding me, I just
bought this everyday business
storytelling book and I
forgot to actually read it
when it arrived.
But one of the lessons
learned I saw--
and it was in your PowerPoints,
like your headers--
or do you have it right there?
Oh, I see you grabbing a book.
Instead of putting like
Q3 results or something
that really doesn't
mean anything
at all at the top
of your PowerPoint,
actually putting the value there
and what you're trying to show.
Alan, I see you had some
thoughts on this too.
Do you want to jump in next?
And if you change your mind
and want to jump in after,
let me know.
Anybody else have any thoughts
on the data storytelling piece.
I think Adam, you
were sharing something
about a course you took?
Yeah.
If you've ever read the
storytelling with data book.
It's super great way
to think about how
to distill a draft down there.
Yeah.
It's like, how do you distill
the graph down to its essence.
And the workshop I took with
them was really interesting
because they really
focus hard on every graph
should just have one big idea.
And if you're not telling one
single individual isolated
story with that graphic,
it's going to confuse people.
And so you should just
keep working on refining
that until it's just that
one story and then make
it super obvious
what you're actually
trying to say with a title that
says, sales decreased whatever,
last quarter.
That's the whole story.
So just being super
clear and making sure
that each slide, each exhibit
is just one specific thing you
want to get across because
people are so bad at juggling
what they've learned so
far in your presentation
and what they're looking at now
and then thinking about what
they're going have for lunch.
And so making it as
simple as possible
to get that message across.
Definitely.
That makes me think about the
conversation about presenting
to our executives as well.
Having one thing in mind when
you are meeting with them,
have a tendency.
Because you don't get
somebody's time all the--
as often as you want,
you want to tell them
everything in that 30
minute meeting instead
of focusing on one.
Mike, I see your hand up.
Yeah.
This is just following on
from what Adams just said.
Yes, absolutely.
I would love if that
was the way that we
presented data and graphs.
But there's also the
tension that says, well,
if anyone takes this
graph out of context copy
paste it and it winds
up in front of the CEO
and none of the context is there
because I'm not presenting it,
then I must cram
every single hedging
statement onto this graph.
And so the actual
useful stuff becomes
like the litter
box in the middle
with all of that extra fluff.
I so wish that we could have it
so that your graph isn't just
a static thing, but
it has hover overs
or whatever else
you need to convey
that additional
contextual information.
But I think the
danger is that people
try and have a graph that
meets the needs of 15
different parties.
First slides that
have a button--
what's your business function?
Click that and then it's going
to fill everything in for you
based on that function.
And it might say,
no, you can't see this.
That's right.
Or best call me,
it's complicated.
Well actually, do you
always put your like contact
information on graphs
and slides you put out?
Does anybody do that?
No.
Oh, yeah
[INAUDIBLE] the idea though.
Yeah--
It's complicated.
I worked for an organization
that did always have--
every dashboard and
thing had a thing.
Somebody to contact within
the organization that made it
or who owns the data behind it.
I started doing that
on random Google Docs
that I share across the
company, making sure
that my name is
at the top of it.
So if anybody has
questions, they
know who originally made
this and to reach out to me.
I had a leader
a couple of years
ago ask if we could put
QR codes next to the plots
that we put in the slide
as a way for people
to get in touch with
more information.
And sure enough, there's an R
package that can make QR code.
So there you go.
I see somebody had asked a
question anonymously that was,
no matter how much I
practice, they always panic
when I have a presentation.
Does anybody have tips
you'd like to share
regarding public speaking?
Yes.
Have a quick
one, do a podcast.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
It actually did help
me, though honestly, so.
So it would be unnatural
not to feel nervous.
Everyone feels nervous.
Even the people that don't
look as though they're nervous
are nervous.
It's just they're
managing those nerves.
The other thing I tend to
think of is, talk to people
as though you're just having
a conversation with friends.
Don't use language that is more
complex than you would normally
use or--
I know some people work well
with they can put on a persona
or put on a hat in
order to present.
But honestly, I tend
to just picking out
one or two people
in the audience
and just talk to them like
I was having a conversation.
Kaitlin, I see you
have your hand raised.
Yeah, Mike, those were
really great points.
Feel like I can talk about this.
I just finished a one hour
workshop at a conference.
So I think the biggest
tip-- and yeah,
you hit the nail on the head.
Of course, you're
going to be nervous.
Like 30 minutes before, my hands
were sweating and I was like,
oh gosh, am I going
to completely blank.
But no, I think once you--
so something I do is
I count myself down
because really, it only
takes one second of courage
because once you're up there,
you can't really go back.
So it's in my head, I'm 3,
2, 1, go, and then you go.
And I think during
the start of my,
I guess, public speaking
engagements or career,
I did put on a
persona and stuff.
But now that I've
done it more and more,
it's your best bet to just
be yourself and talk to the--
and I think it's so
important to remember,
I feel like public speaking
it's so easy to just focus on
yourself and how
you may be perceived
by the audience this and that.
But most of the
time, the audience
is just there to learn.
So in whatever way
you can provide value
without just being so in your
head about what you look like,
what you sound like, what
content you're even presenting,
yeah, I think it's so
important just to remember
why the audience is there.
And they're there to learn.
And then the one last thing that
I can say about public speaking
that's really helped me is if
you are doing a public speaking
engagement, do
something on a topic
that you feel very
comfortable talking about.
That you could
talk on this topic
for hours and hours and hours.
Because I've done presentations
where I didn't really feel
super confident about the topic.
Once I did a workshop
on data visualizations.
And although I had spent a
whole year not making a data
visualization at all, I was just
doing data analysis pipelines
in R. So that public
speaking engagement, I was--
I remember I was so
nervous because I
didn't feel so confident on
the topic I was presenting.
So yeah, just make sure
your topic really well.
And then I think from there,
it can flow really natural.
Those are all great points.
What you were saying,
Caitlin, was just
making me think about,
sometimes what has been helpful
for me is to reach out to
a few people who I know
are going to be
there ahead of time,
and just asking them maybe
questions about what they would
like to learn or--
I don't know, just
reaching out to them in--
--general to talk to them.
Because then at least part of
what I am providing or sharing
is providing value to
somebody in the audience,
and it makes me a
lot less nervous.
I guess also helps with
any imposter syndrome too
to know that this is going
to be valuable for at least
these people.
So chances are, it will be
valuable for their other peers
that are too.
Yeah.
No, for sure.
And even yesterday,
I was talking--
so I presented today
and then the conference
was yesterday and today.
And I was talking to people
who registered for my workshop
and that made me
feel so much better.
And even seeing them
today in the audience,
those were the ones that I
was looking at and talking to.
You know what I mean?
Absolutely I was just
talking with my coworker who's
going to a Pi data
conference about this too.
And I was just saying, if we do
have a list of who is attending
and if you can reach out to
somebody on LinkedIn ahead
of time or just
introduce yourself,
it makes you feel so much more
comfortable when you're there,
that you at least know somebody.
Any other thoughts or tips?
I really liked Ahnas' tip
about dressing comfortably.
Dressing something that
you're comfortable wearing
and that you're not going
to be constantly thinking
about what you're wearing,
that's super important.
Absolutely.
I've noticed that if I
have a presentation to do,
I'll pick an outfit that
makes me very comfortable.
I'll even get a haircut or
I'll do something like--
Yes.
Those are little things
that will definitely
make you feel better.
Yeah.
Minimize all the other stuff.
The peripheral stuff that
could make you nervous,
that's not you
speaking because you
don't need that in your life.
You're already nervous enough.
Absolutely.
I see a few people talking
about Toastmasters.
Has anybody been
part of Toastmasters?
I'm seeing some nods.
I've never been.
A lot of places
will let you drop
in if you want to go to a group
and say, hey, I'm interested
but I'm not sure if
I want to do this.
A lot of them are really happy
to have you spectate and clap
for people when they
finish and stuff like that.
So I recommend anybody
who would check it out.
But it's usually
not data focused.
There's a good topic
each time, each session.
It's not data, but helpful.
Cool.
I've done super technical
data talks to them,
and it's helpful because
talking to an audience who
has no idea what your
domain knowledge is
can make you like, oh, OK.
I have to make sure this
jargon is to a minimum,
and I have to explain this
like I'm explaining it
to a really smart junior high
student instead of my peers.
So it can be really helpful.
They also have-- a
meeting as an hour,
and they will have three
scheduled big presentations,
like 15, 20 minutes, but
they also have little drills.
And even as a first
timer, you can go and try
one of the little drills where
you get up for 30 seconds
and they ask you
something, and you just
have to speak off the
cuff and it works out
some of those jitters.
Even if you're introverted,
even if you're scared,
it's worth doing because
if it doesn't scare you,
won't change you.
Totally worth doing though.
Everybody should go
to one Toastmaster
meeting in their life, I'd say.
Cool.
We had for the POSIT conference,
all the accepted speakers
get speaker training
through articulation.
So I got to go through
that last year.
And it was really helpful
to think about starting off
your talk with a story.
Framing things as a story
to bring the audience in.
And I've been starting to try
and do that with presentations
that I give internally as well.
Like who is the customer
that this is impacting
and why are we-- why am
I presenting this too?
Jared, I see you had asked
a question in the chat
a little bit earlier.
I'm sorry we didn't
get to it until now.
Do you want to jump in?
And Jared, I'll read--
oh, I can see you unmuted.
There you go.
Am I now?
Can you guys hear?
Yes.
Sure.
This is just more open ended
for anybody's experience
when it comes to giving
presentations or--
I mean, I know it has more
to do with the audience
that you're in front of, but
trying to avoid the sales pitch
type of presentation versus
keeping things much more
unbiased and just presenting.
Giving an unbiased approach
to what you're presenting
instead of trying to push
an agenda essentially.
Because I've gone
both ways where
if I'm trying to essentially
persuade decision
makers on my idea
or pitch my idea,
then it obviously
becomes straight
into a sales pitch scenario.
But I've also tried to
just do presentations
on giving the information in
a very unbiased disseminating
the information to the public
audience type scenario.
And I always run
the gamut gambit
of how to not include your own
personal bias when presenting
and try to keep things very
open, if that makes sense.
Just wanted to get
everybody's opinion.
Anybody have thoughts
to share there?
Kind of want Jim
to explain himself.
Again, we're tool people and
maybe even statisticians here.
What we bring in terms of our
backgrounds and skills matters.
And so more often than
not, the opening slide
is going to say who
we are and process
we may be used to arrive at
this piece of information,
and that's a pitch.
Now, bias may be
implies that we've
imprinted something unnatural
or a distortion on this,
and I don't mean to
misconstrue what you--
construe what you said there.
But I don't undersell
the skills we
bring as people to
the conversations
with our organizations, whether
it's a government institution
or a charity or a business.
We bring something that's
valuable and hugely valuable,
in fact.
So we shouldn't be ashamed
to imprint that on the work
we've done, and the
results that we've arrived.
At least that's where
I'm coming from.
Great points, Jim.
Thank you.
Well, thank you all so much for
joining today and winging it
with us.
This has been really fun.
I appreciate everybody
jumping in here
and being the
featured leader too.